[Music]  r-e-s-p-e-c-t  find out what it means to me  r-e-s-p-e-c-t  take care  [Music]  well first of all aretha franklin is  iconic um  and can't be matched so uh recording  this song i was very excited but also  nervous because  you know i want to do it justice so i  just tried to get into the spirit of  what the song is about  and ultimately i had a lot of fun  recording it  [Music]  to me respect means people respecting my  boundaries appreciating me  treating me right the loved ones in my  life  i don't even know how to explain it but  i feel like respect is a self-value  self-esteem how you see yourself in the  world how you feel you deserve to be  treated  [Music]  and guess what  [Music]  wow what would i say to claire about  love i don't know i'm not a  love guru but i would just say to have  fun and no matter what the outcome is  it was a lesson and just make sure you  enjoy the ride  you